if you don't start a business around
something that you are intensely
passionate about you're going to fail
and most entrepreneurs get it wrong they
start a business just trying to make a
lot of money and they'll write into me
and say evan i want to make a lot of
money what business should i start and
that's the entirely wrong approach
the guys who started business just
trying to make money rarely do
if you look at any successful
entrepreneur at the core is always an
intense passion for what they're doing
and the desire to help people
starting a business is going to be one
of the most
grueling and cruel experiences you can
ever wish on somebody
you're going to get beaten down every
day people are going to say no they're
going to reject you they're going to
call you stupid
and you're going to question yourself
you're gonna wonder if this was a good
idea or not you're gonna wonder if you
should go back and just get a job you're
gonna wonder if you just made the
biggest mistake of your life
by starting this business
and the only thing that gets you through
the only thing that gets you through is
that intense passion for what you're
doing and knowing that you're helping
people
i remember when i first started helping
entrepreneurs i was asked to do a
presentation at the ymca
and i spent weeks preparing for this i
was excited to do it
and
we had a room full of chairs and i
remember walking into the building
full of excitement full of confidence
getting up the elevator walking into the
room and my heart sank
room full of chairs
weeks of promotion
three people showed up
and i wondered what's this what am i
doing what a waste of time
but the show must go on
and i delivered my presentation
it was awesome
and i helped those people that day i
touched them and i knew after that
presentation that i had to keep going
and doing this and i had no idea how it
was going to work out but i had to do it
even it was only three people at a time
this is what i was born to do and what
got me excited every day so i had to
keep doing it
and that's the scariest part
because quite often you have no idea how
the dots are going to connect but you
have to trust that somewhere in the
future
those dots will connect it will make
sense somewhere down the line and you
have to have the courage to keep going
forward even though
all you see around you is darkness
and that only comes
when you love what you're doing and you
know you're helping people
so if you're just starting a business
and you're thinking about different
ideas don't settle don't just try to
find something that's going to make you
a lot of money
you have to build a business around
something that you are intensely
passionate about and you know will help
a lot of people good luck